[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola mi nombre es jessica tengo 30 años
y la calle fue mi primera escuela nací
en santiago del estero en una familia
muy humilde y cuando era chica nos
mudamos a gonzález catán partido de la
matanza donde me críe y estudie mi mamá
no sabe leer ni escribir y nunca tuvo un
trabajo fuera de casa mis hermanos más
grandes tampoco el barrio y la falta de
oportunidades te lleva a pensar el día a
día hasta te quita los sueños cuando yo
tenía 15 años falleció mi papá y ahí
decidí hacer algo diferente con mi vida
nadie me incentivo estudiar pero me
impulsaron las ganas de ayudar la misma
por ejemplo a tener su jubilación me
propuse a terminar la secundaria y fue
todo un desafío y un logro porque soy la
primera en la familia en hacerlo
como les dije la calle fue mi primera
escuela yo era vendedora ambulante vendí
de todo en la calle vendí plantas vendí
medias vendía el pan casero casi a mi
mamá en el horno de barro
nos levantábamos con mis hermanos a eso
de las 6 de la mañana y a las 8 salíamos
a vender arrancábamos por el fondo
caminábamos kilómetros y kilómetros
una vez camine 16 horas y no vendí nada
se imaginan lo que fue eso es terrible
la angustia que se siente cuando no
puedes traer el plato de comida a tu
casa
en estos momentos te preguntas qué hago
mañana salgo con lo mismo cambio pero no
hay muchas oportunidades
la calle también me dio mis grandes
maestros mis compañeros de escuela y
otros vendedores ambulantes que estaban
ahí para ayudarme y aconsejar me en lo
que podía llegar a vender
nunca me voy a olvidar el día que me
robaron todo en ese momento yo vendía
mercadería sábanas y cortinas para un
hombre que nos daba a pagar vinieron
unos chicos y me robaron todo corrí
llore
tenía una bronca pero ellos estaban ahí
acompañándome
también tuve mis momentos lindos mis
recreos hice muchos amigos que sigo
cruzando en el barrio
llegó un momento donde dije basta esto
no es para mí yo estoy para más en la
vida en ese momento una amiga me habló
del centro de formación joven levántate
en el barrio no tenemos a la de salud
cercana los chicos salen del secundario
sin saber leer ni escribir no tenemos
trabajo y estamos lejos de todo pero el
joven levántate yo me capacité y no
obtuve un certificado obtuve más de 15
que me sirvieron para pensar mejor
uno de los cursos que hice fue armado de
castilla nos enseñaban a armar paneles y
a unirlos y así tengo mi casa atrás del
terreno de la casa de mi mamá y me
siento feliz
el último curso que hice fue el de
reparación de electrodomésticos marcó un
antes y un después en mi vida y en la de
mis compañeros
y saben por qué porque no solamente nos
enseñaban a reparar electrodomésticos
sino que nos dieron herramientas
esenciales para crear nuestro propio
negocio
en estos momentos conocidos montones de
personas personas que recién terminaban
el secundario madres solteras personas
presas hoy todas estas gentes son mis
socios pensamos en crear un futuro mejor
y tenemos la tranquilidad de tener
ingresos fijos
la pandemia tampoco nos detuvo hasta
tuvimos más trabajo que nunca con mis
compañeros nos preguntábamos qué hubiese
pasado si si nuestro negocio yo era
vendedor ambulante no hubiese podido
vender nada mis compañeros en esos
momentos
siempre estaban ahí apoyándome como les
dije la calle fue mi primera escuela
pero joven levántate es mi segunda o mi
universidad
hasta acá mi historia aparece de
autosuperación más y con un final feliz
pero hoy quiero contarles algo que
aprendí
aprendí la importancia de rodearme con
personas que me ayudan a crecer como
silvia y andrea que son las referentes
del centro de formación que siempre con
tanta honestidad están dispuestas a
transmitir todo lo que saben
la calle me enseñó a ser más comprensiva
con los demás
en el barrio conocí a un chico que tenía
12 y yo tenía 15 él siempre se ponía
triste porque no podía vender y yo le
decía que se quedara tranquilo que así
era la venta que a veces se vendía y a
veces no pero que no había que perder la
fe en uno hasta le ofrecí para que
vendiéramos juntos para que no se sienta
solo hoy lo sigo cruzando en el barrio
trabaja en casa quintás porque hizo un
curso de mantenimiento en un centro de
formación que le indique
la calle me enseñó a sobretodo a
emprender a entender que la pobreza no
pasa sólo por los bolsillos se trata de
probar de intentar todas las veces que
sean necesarios yo nunca me detengo ni
nada me detiene estudiando aprendí a
dejar la pobreza de lado y al
transformar cada espacio con
herramientas que tengo
después de que terminamos el curso de
formación con mis socios comenzamos a
darle forma a nuestra unidad productiva
a un principio las mujeres delegamos las
tareas de los hombres pero después nos
dimos cuenta de que todos podíamos
fue muy interesante el proceso
teníamos que acordar con todo lo que
pasaba allí adentro con horarios también
tareas administrativas logísticas
equipos reparados acomodarlos a reparar
repuestos una vez que estuvimos listos
arrancamos constantemente le estamos
buscando la forma para trabajar mejor
de mis compañeros aprendí a trabajar en
equipo a entender que hay realidades
diferentes a la mía y a respetar su
manera de pensar también aprendo a
rodearme con clientes nuevos o personas
que se acercan para ayudarnos
tener un trabajo es muy importante para
crear el futuro antes pensaba en el día
a día cómo traer el plato de comida en
mi casa hoy
tengo un trabajo en donde puedo
proyectar mi futuro todos los meses me
propongo una meta
con paciencia ahorro y puedo comprarme
lo que quiera como les dije la calle fue
mi primera escuela no sé si la mejor no
sé si es la que deseo para las personas
que veo luchando la como lo hice yo mi
deseo es que a nadie le falta en la
escuela porque estoy segura que es el
lugar donde despertar creas y activas
donde realmente aprovechar las
oportunidades no dejes de pasar de largo
para seguir formándote porque la
educación siempre transforma tu vida
para mejor
cuál es tu escuela hoy
gracias
e
[Música]
[Aplausos]